[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the show where we help people
build wealth do work that you love and
create amazing and actual
relationships christina ellis number one
best-selling author and ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
talk about your life right in front of
you open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
let's start off this hour with landon in
memphis hi landon how are you
how's it going dave i appreciate you
taking my call sure what's up
so i'm 24 or 25 and my wife is 24 we're
in baby step 7 and we're looking to
upgrade here
at a house that we have potentially to
buy it's 275 the house come in right now
is about 2 30. um and so i have the cash
obviously to upgrade and we obviously
paying cash but i want to know if it'd
be stupid to upgrade or if i should just
sit around and be patient and the reason
we want to buy it is because it's a
friend of ours and they just weren't
going to put it on the market where we
didn't have to deal with the
competitiveness of it and it would just
be a clean you know purchase without
having to deal with other offers and
stuff
um but my only really hang up is is the
area isn't really the nicest area in the
world it's not it's not bad but like the
house directly across is an older
gentleman and he doesn't really keep up
with his property really well like i
mean the graph might get away with them
and there might be you know just kind of
things all over the yard but you know i
just afraid that if i want to resell it
that that might hurt me potentially or
you know i don't know what do you think
what do you make
about 180. you're killing it dude
freaking 24 years old with a paid for
house and asking questions like this
you're stud well done appreciate you
appreciate it man it's amazing beautiful
um well a couple things just pop into my
head just listening to your story i mean
there's nothing wrong with anything
you're saying
um
i it doesn't sound like much of an
upgrade
well it would be significantly more of
an upgrade honestly
the house right now would probably wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait you're talking about forty
thousand dollars oh no no no that's yeah
so i'm talking about an upgrade in house
i know but i mean how are you getting so
much more house for only 40 grand more
well the reason is because
my buddy that's selling it to me he's a
flipper and he's going to give us a
pretty substantial discount on it would
go for about 325 on the market
and it would be about 800 more square
feet and it's significantly nicer
is really what i'm saying the only
downside is the goob across the street
well you know the area in general isn't
the nicest so i mean one street over
half a million dollar houses and then
you know it's this street and they're
probably in the 250s the 260s
um
oh yes sir i mean it would but i'm
talking about the last time these were
sold
you know two three four five years ago
well that's not nice
you know what we're asking is what's
worth today you're saying it's a 350 000
street today and the house is one block
over a half million
right
i mean i'm not seeing a lot of minuses
in this situation that's pretty
incredible for this market to be able to
have that kind of deal that's that
sounds incredible what is your
hesitation right now aside from the area
aside from the neighbor do you have any
other things holding you back
yeah so it would just be spending the
amount of money cash
right now you know like i don't know
should i just be patient and pile up
cash or you know because i mean we are
saying oh you're a tight wide you don't
want to let go of the money dave dave i
am a penny pincher yeah now i know how
you got here okay yeah and it's killing
you to spend your little bank account
that's what it is
i can't really emotionally what's your
wife say about this deal
she's the same exact way she loves the
house
not too happy about the area and you
know but she's okay five years from
today are you going to be glad you
bought it
i would say yes
not just financially but also in living
there and living in that specific house
i think we would be i think we would be
you're not gonna be whining about the
neighborhood five years from now no i i
don't think we would be and you know
another main reason we wanted to sell it
because we badly want to get out of
where we're in now okay most
neighborhoods
most neighborhoods are getting better or
getting worse there isn't very few
neighborhoods that are staying exactly
the same five years from today five
years from today do you think this one
will be better or worse no it will be
better it's a very trending
town okay quit being a tight wide and by
the house soon
okay
okay you know if you if you don't think
this is impulsive you have pain
you haven't done anything impulsive
since you were 12.
that that's true
you're
i understand i understand i know you and
i and i appreciate that about you
because it's what got you to where you
are and it's actually but like with most
of us our greatest strength can be our
greatest weakness and in this case
you're getting paralysis of the analysis
because you get a joy from holding on to
that money
so the resale doesn't make you afraid in
any way if the guy you told me the
neighborhood was getting better
it
is ain't worried about the old man
across the street he's going to die and
his re heirs are going to sell the place
right right okay i'm just afraid that if
i wanted to resell it in five to seven
years that somebody would tone away
because of what the neighbor's house
looked like if it's one neighbor and the
rest of the neighborhood's getting
better i'm not worried about that and
whenever you go to sell maybe you can
ask him if you can mow his lawn
just take a day and fix it up for him
yeah yeah yeah we used to do that we had
a guy in the neighborhood we would all
just show up and clean up his yard you
know but that was a different world
though yeah you did that now people
shoot at you but
um yeah it's crazy that's fun though
that that's a really cool question from
a really cool young man yeah 24 years
old on baby step 7 wanting to upgrade
houses and has the cash to do it that is
awesome there's so so little i had to
correct in that call i'm just sitting
here amazed you know i mean he's already
so far ahead of the game
and uh for those of you don't know baby
step 7 means he has zero debt has a
fully funded emergency fund is putting
15 percent of his income away for
retirement household income and if they
have kids he's funding b he's funding
kids college funds so that that's all
the babysitter babystep 7 is the last of
our steps and it's basically become very
wealthy and very generous
which by the way is always good for
tight wads to do the generosity thing
too because it helps you loosen up a
little bit
helps you enjoy your money a little bit
more
yeah and i'd way rather him be a tight
wad than just freely spending and
irresponsible
that's incredible just makes him it
makes him a unicorn he's awesome he's
beautiful beautiful situation he's got
his family and
i mean they're going to be
multi-millionaires by the time they're
30 right you know at the rate he's going
so making 182 80 000 a year by the way
yeah it gives me so much hope for the
future generation i feel like it's often
so easy to dog on the younger kids
coming up and say they're irresponsible
but from what we're seeing walking
through this lobby and coming onto the
show it's like man we are seeing some
incredible people in their 20s which is
just super inspiring yeah yeah i mean
the 20s got their group too but
everybody's got their group right but
this bunch but there's a bunch of good
ones in this batch
it really is and we're running into them
everywhere we go and
being very smart very wise um very
careful
the the this particular z generation is
they're a little more serious
there's not a lot of flower children
among them well they've been through a
lot you know they've seen a lot of
financial struggle they've seen a
pandemic a lot of them are realizing you
gotta get on your stuff now
yeah i guess i feel like most of us have
been through some stuff but this this
generation like they're they're on it
they're game on i like them i love it
good bunch
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions
about your wealth your work that you
love and actual amazing relationships
mike is with us in philly hey mike
welcome to the ramsey show
thanks dave uh happy that you took my
phone call and uh
thanks for giving me the tools to really
change my life i really appreciate it
i'm honored how can i help
so i'm on baby steps four five and six
and
ever since i paid off my debt and
got my full emergency fund
um i i'm saving up for a house but the
last six months
i've been going over budget
and i just feel like i've sort of lost
that
gazelle intensity
um
regarding my budget and expenses
and i just wanted to know if you had any
tips
to help you sort of get back on track
mike what what motivates you to succeed
financially what gets you excited
whenever you think about saving and
money
um i i don't know i guess just the idea
of living free and
being able to do what i want i mean i
was under so much pressure from debt for
so long and so
like such a big part of my life
that like this this sense of freedom
that's been really
my
you know
i guess
my passion or my uh
uh
how old are you i mean
i'm 37 what do you do for a living
i work in philanthropy
so you're a development guy
uh yes okay cool um
well one thing one clarification once
you're in baby steps four five and six
we don't teach gazelle intensity we say
move from intensity to intentionality
but even that you're violating because
you're going over budget you're not
being intentional because you're not
doing with your money your money's not
doing what you want it to do because
you're goofing up
that's what you're telling me so even
that you're not being intentional
because you're not living on your budget
so that you can
uh
buy the house right now is your budget
too tight
uh it probably is are you single
yes are you a saver or a spender by
nature i used to be a spender but i
think i've become a bit of a saver
except that part where you fell off the
budget and didn't save
yeah well i mean i'm still
i you know to be perfectly honest i'm
that i'm still putting money into my
retirement account
uh that's just
you should be from my yeah you should
well that's okay if you do if you want
to do that while you're saving for the
house that's not that's okay sometimes
maybe at baby step 3b people stop their
retirement sometimes they keep
retirement going while they're saving
for a house either one's okay
nothing is violated there you're more
asking about motivation so if your
budget is reasonable for you to live on
you're not having to strain and hold
your breath like you were back in baby
steps one through three instead you're
just in a you went from a sprint to now
you're in a marathon you feel the
difference
yeah and if in that cadence that rhythm
your budget is reasonable then you've
got to start asking yourself okay
what do i want more
this donut
or this or are these eight pounds that
this donut's going to put on me these
are questions i ask myself every day
so i mean it's like like i saw a bumper
sticker one time
nothing tastes as good as it feels to be
thin
yeah you know i might argue that but
that's a good bumper sticker so you know
um but the uh uh you know you know
is it worth it
to not do that thing that's a budget
buster
in order to get your house
yeah you probably need to get like
pictures of houses that you like and put
them on your refrigerator
it's not a bad idea
that's not a bad idea kind of getting a
visual in front of you that's punching
you in the nose every so often and
you're going wait a minute i've already
spent my restaurant budget if i go out
to eat three more times this week and
screw around with this money i'm not
ever getting a house
yeah
yeah that's what i was gonna say is it's
so important to have your why be clear
like you need to know why you're
fighting why you're saving why you're
budgeting um i love that you're in
philanthropy and you're already a giving
person
one of the huge motivations of getting
to baby step seven is so that you can
give and live like no one else so like
dave said said get a picture of the
house that you want get take some time
by yourself and just think through you
know why am i doing this what is
inspiring to me whenever i reach baby
step 7 when i have that paid for house
you know what can i do with that money
how can i give back what charities are
excited about the other thing that helps
um most of us is to have community
around us while we're trying to be
accountable
and to be encouraged
and to have some people in our lives and
so if you've been through financial
peace university
i have not okay i'm gonna put you
through that and get you into some of
those groups
and let those and just tell those groups
you need to be real with a group and go
hey group
y'all gotta hold me accountable because
you're gonna be you know the good news
is you're single and you don't have to
convince somebody else to do this the
bad news is there's nobody ragging on
you if you mess it up
yeah
and so uh but you so you need some
people in your corner that are calling
you out and reminding you what's real
and what's important because you already
know all this stuff you're obviously a
bright guy
you know how to do this so
um pretty cool man i think you're gonna
be fine the good news is you actually
had a budget that said wait a minute
you're off the bat you're off the path
you hit the guardrail get back in the
lane
it's telling you right it's screaming at
you and that's you didn't even have that
before so now the numbers hold you
accountable they wake you up and go wait
wait wait wait rick is in springfield
missouri hey rick welcome to the ramsey
show
thank you dave thank you kelly
how can we help
oh man i just inherited a million
dollars for my mom i'm disabled and i
don't know what to do i'm married i got
two special needs kids um
i get like 1100 a month of disability
check
and now with all this money coming i
need help so that it's not just proof up
in smoke
i need to invest it so that my wife how
old are you income
i'm going to be 50 this year what's the
nature of your disability sir
a car accident
i got caught up in a 45-car pileup
yeah but i mean what happened to you
oh i had an out-of-body experience i
mean
what is the what is your disability your
disability
um the union told me that i may be able
to perform my duties i used to get down
in a 40-50 foot hole and now i feel like
the walls were going to cave in on me so
i wasn't able to do my job i guess
paranoia my job
so anxiety uh yeah from the wreck
is what what they said ahead okay that's
fair how long ago was that
back in 2008 okay is there have you ever
tried to do anything else
i don't like leaving my house in today's
society
me neither but
i get you but uh um okay
does your wife work outside the home
no she's a home goddess she stays at
home and takes care of the kids
and y'all make it on 1100 bucks a month
huh
super budgeted
wow
okay
well the million dollars like you said
could go poof and i appreciate your fear
about that and the way to keep you from
doing that is to
put some folks in your corner to teach
you
not to do it for you
i do not want you going and doing
something because i said to do it or
someone else said to do it
the job of the people in your corner is
that they need to have the market and
i'm scared of that it's hey if you're in
the stock market i don't care if you're
there that's where my my personal
retirement is in the stock market in my
401k i'm not worried about that what i
am worried about is you putting money in
something that you don't understand
and that someone else told you to do it
and you're at you know then then the
money's gone and you're a victim of that
i don't want you being a victim i want
you to be a victor thank you so you are
in control you make the decisions you
sit down with someone
if you want to talk to someone that does
investing the way we teach here on the
air you can click smart vester at ramsey
solutions it'll connect you up with
brokers that do mutual fund investing
the way i personally do it and you can
begin to learn about it
if you're scared of the stock market
right now that's reasonable
but um
you know you can't be scared of
everything and we're in and have this
million dollars make any money it's
going to make a little bit of money on
something
and putting it in a
coffee can burying it in the backyard we
don't have coffee cans anymore putting
it in something and burying it in the
backyard um
is a bad idea that's going to cost you a
hundred thousand dollars a year
so you need to have a little bit of
courage but your courage is going to
come from knowledge
not being rash or being a gambler
you learn about buying a house before
you buy a house and then you don't make
a mistake buying a house
this is the ramsey
[Music]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free homeownership and churchill is
here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsay solutions you can
drop by we have a visitor center and you
can get like free cookies and coffee and
see the place and hang out and watch the
show there's usually
50 to 250 people watching the show out
here and we charge exactly zero for the
entire experience so come by anytime
you're in the nashville franklin area
franklin's a beautiful little town south
of nashville where we live and where we
enjoy our lives in the lobby we also
have a little debt-free stage where
people come to do their debt-free
screams and jorvey jorge and vivara are
with us hey guys how are you great great
thank you where do you guys live in
baltimore awesomeness welcome to
nashville how much debt have you paid
off
230 thousand dollars i love it
and how long did this take
three years and three months good for
you guys and your range of income during
that time that's why i haven't made a
pound
so we started combined income at 120 000
and then after
some side jobs
many side jobs and a lot of moon
lighting we increased it at 180 thousand
dollars good for you what do you guys do
for a living
i am a researcher a medical i'm doing
medical research
and he's an electrical engineer awesome
very cool what kind of debt was your 230
000 oh it was a combination of
medical bills irs
credit cards lots of credit cards
401k loans
and student loans most of it was student
loans sallie
wow
it was all my debt all yours yes she
married into this huh
wow okay so now tell me this is not a
baltimore accent where you guys from
i'm originally from russia
and he's from bolivia oh very cool and
how did how did you two meet
um we met online actually
being in the us in the u.s oh very cool
how long have you been married
four years almost four years very good
and then you decide we're going to go on
this journey three years and three
months ago and boom we hit this how did
you get connected to the ramsey stuff
well
i learned about you a little bit before
i met jorge
and
i just i just got it i paid off my only
one credit card
and when i met him i was so into dave
ramsey that i started talking about
about you like on the first date
oh no
that's true that's against the rules
you're not supposed to do that
and and we signed that for a class no
way yes on the first day
almost almost
yes
so
but
i
for some reason we just didn't follow
through oh and after we married and we
were on a family vacation and she can
tell better
yeah we went into florida and family
vacation natasha was already born she
was two years old two month old and
there was a rainy day and um
we got this message we got the email
that we have two weeks left until the
day ramsey membership expires so
and we're like okay let's just watch it
like give it a shot and we started
watching it and
in two days we just binge watched the
whole the whole disc
and yeah the parts that we wanted to
hear again like
the first step and the second step baby
step and we just kept watching it and
then started watching all we found out
about all the uh the dead free screams
and we just couldn't stop and we just
love that
you guys were all in so tell us about
the journey what did you guys do to get
out of debt oh
what we did everything
i i took maybe we don't know
i i did pizza delivery i did
amazon
jobs on the
weekends nights and holidays uh i did
uber driving and then i i figured that i
could do moonlighting and i started
doing moonlighting and that's what uh
gave me the most
with the coronavirus it actually worked
out
i shouldn't say that but it worked out
well
in the case that uh they were people
were more worked out well for the
plexiglass people too so it's okay
there was so much work in amazon
they meeted people and so i took
as many shifts as i could and then for
the
moonlighting i do
cat drafting and
revit modeling and i started just doing
my own beam consulting
gig and
it just
when the coronavirus hit
the businesses were more willing to
hire me remote
and i just
went gasoline pants that's amazing so
y'all watched financial piece multiple
times you worked around the clock did
people think you were crazy
definitely yeah definitely yes
um 230 000 in three years that's
impressive yes i mean you've lived on
nothing oh yeah oh my goodness yeah we
lived before when we just married we
wanted to have a nice life you know we
live in like almost like good apartment
in suburbs yeah with 1600 square feet
but once we got in the journey
we moved from this to the city to
baltimore in the shoebox basically it
was 400 feet no ac
it was it was
almost inhumane like our our parents
thought we were nuts
because she was five months when we
moved and they they refused to come for
a while because it was just
no cost it was really uncomfortable we
didn't even have a table to eat dinner
or lunch we were eating in the couch we
sold everything on craigslist i saw all
my ins i played music i play uh guitar
and drums and i sold all my instruments
uh because i didn't even have the space
and i was working so much that i didn't
have time to play with them anyway so i
just gave up all of that
um yeah it was
was it worth it oh yes
because now i can go to a guitar center
and buy myself a better guitar
anything you want anything they want as
long as you make a couple hundred
thousand dollars a year and you don't
have any debt yes yeah that puts you in
a completely and you got a baby i mean
life is good and nothing but a beautiful
opportunity in front of you yes you two
are amazing thank you thank you amazing
oh and we tripled my income of course of
course we did yes
so what do you tell people who think it
can't be done who feel like they're
overwhelmed you know maybe multiple six
figures in debt like you all had what do
you tell them right now
well
first
get on the get on the budget
and just just do it don't question it
don't question it because we knew people
who started doing that and just start
analyzing it too much doing too much
math it's not mathematical yeah just
just do it just follow it like this
you know it works and i don't know how
to convince other people that it just
works it works
i think just go to work yeah look at the
look at the uh the weather forecast and
when you see rain in florida go get in
the hotel room and binge watch fpu and
that that's that's the formula right
there
yeah i love it also i would i would say
we we were watching a lot of day free
screams a lot dead free screams and even
oatmeal
every morning it was a routine natasha
was one year or one year old already yes
and we were eating the same oatmeal
every morning and we're watching just
day free scream like crazy people i will
not eat oatmeal anymore
i love it all right i love it beautiful
all right let's bring beautiful natasha
up and uh what a great russian name to
your heritage there i love it natasha
she's a princess
how beautiful is she now how old is she
now she's three and a half
so you have a new country
you have a new marriage
you have a new baby and you have a new
future
you guys are pretty cool
thank you this is pretty neat you got
opportunity in front of you like
nobody's business medical researcher
electrical engineer
you guys can do anything you want to do
wait i'm actually in pa school now i
decided to switch careers she stopped
working why not some time ago and we're
cash flowing we were paying off debt and
cash flow in her school okay well why
not i like it very well done you guys
are something else i got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that's the
next chapter in your story for sure
you'll be there in 20 minutes the way
you two are rolling you're fun to watch
all right it's jorge and varvara and
natasha from baltimore
230 000 paid off in three years three
months making 120 to 180 what a
wonderful story count it down let's hear
a debt-free scream
one two three four
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
they are cool
wow
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
well there's a lot of crazy out there
folks are looking for direction on how
to handle their
lives and their money
but they're also struggling to see how
it's even possible to build wealth with
all the
news when you read the news you think oh
my goodness when you watch the news you
think oh my goodness well don't
[Laughter]
quit
hey we want you to come to one of our
building wealth live events
we're going to walk you through all the
crazy and teach you the steps to build
real wealth lasting wealth the financial
principles we teach are the only
principles that work
in prosperous times
and in hard times
and no matter where you are with your
money you can get on a path to building
wealth
now the building wealth live tour has
already made a couple of awesome stops
with complete sellouts in las vegas and
orlando
we've wrapped up our spring portion and
now we're looking towards the fall we
have four dates in the fall
and these are all over 75 to 80 sold out
already
but you can still get tickets to phoenix
september the 13th sacramento
november the 1st minneapolis november
the 10th san antonio november the 15th
rachel cruz george campbell ken coleman
dr john deloney and me
we're all going to be there we'll be
signing books taking pictures answering
questions
it's going to be a blast and of course
we're going to be doing the building
wealth live event tickets are only
twenty five dollars you can get a four
pack of tickets starting at sixty
dollars bring your friends in other
words you can you and your wife your
husband bring a couple friends with you
for all for 60 bucks that's a deal it's
going to be amazing ramsay solutions.com
events and reserve your seats now seth
is in detroit hi seth welcome to the
ramsey show
hey how you doing better than i deserve
what's up
so
my question for today um so i actually i
did the dave ramsey course back in high
school um which is about five years ago
but um did all like the baby steps and
um kind of i fell away from it a little
bit and now i'm starting to get back
into it but um i'm recently engaged
congratulations when you get married
uh next year or august of next year so
yeah um so we're really excited about
that but um
yeah so one of the things um is she is a
spender by nature and i'm more of a
saver
by nature
which i find is a beautiful thing for
our relationship but also we are
um recently just trying to come together
to
be more intentional about how we can
like unify
our finances and and cutting down our
debt um and something that
i'm my question is is that so right now
i'm uh dwindling my debt and hopefully
in the next six months i'm hopefully
going to be debt-free
completely and so
she has about
about twenty-five thousand dollars in
that and then i have about five thousand
dollars in debt um and so
something we talked about was if uh once
i'm done paying off my debt
would it be feasible for me to
uh help start paying off her debt before
we get married so that okay
so why is that
well i mean
you're not married yet so there's always
a chance that between now and next
august something could happen um you
know obviously that's that's a bit of
time we're well over a year so
um just to take that risk is is a bit
risky and just not what we recommend
yeah you do it it'll also impact your
relationship
um when you start paying debts off and
paying bills for somebody you're not
married to it's a power play
and even if you don't mean it you don't
sound like a guy that does toxic power
plays i don't think it's you i don't
think you're a bad guy but it's just it
changes the power structure of the
relationship when uh one of you is
paying for everything or paying off
everything one of you is responsible one
of you is not it can build up resentment
it can do all this other stuff instead
what i would tell you to do i love the
idea that you're talking about it
and you're beginning to communicate
about it
and um let me ask you a personal
question do you mind why are you waiting
19 months to get married
uh just because we're we're saving you
wanting to save up for but not it's not
like a huge grandeur's wedding but we're
uh so she currently works at ywam which
is used with emissions yeah no no no no
no
no
yeah so she's doing that and so she's
finishing up like her obligations with
that and then was doing a bible school
and so there was a lot of like
uh barriers just for us to get like we
tried to get married this year but it
was just way more stress and we felt um
we just felt like the lord was like
leading us to get married next year um
and like
uh that was kind of the main reason what
do you mean and just to be able to
i make around 62 000 a year good for you
okay
and so she's she's living on uh
donations and then going to bible school
on donations right
yeah yeah and so that was kind of like
part of the reason why i wanted to start
helping i guess like because i do give
to the mission already um every month to
help support her um
just like and i also give it like other
missionaries but um that's just
something that we um
kind of agreed on it it's like because
she's in missions that was
kind of a way to support but i know that
can still get muddy yeah
and it's all about it's all about if
you'll do a good bible study on unity
and on the power of it that's what
you're creating you're creating you know
like when you walk down the aisle the
preacher says and now you are one
right but until then you're not
right yeah and that's the danger that
you're violating and you can get
yourself in a mess and and it changes it
can be subtle little things it could
change the way your mother feels towards
her
right when she figures out you're paying
off her dad it might not change the way
you treated her or it might change the
way she feels i'll give you an example
that when we went broke we were married
though in this case but it still had the
same effect uh we went broke many years
ago sharon's dad who's the nicest man on
the planet he's like a saint
he he loaned us a little money to catch
the house up so we didn't lose it in
bankruptcy
until i got that debt paid he never said
a single unkind word
never looked at me once she never said
anything it drove me bananas
thanksgiving dinner just didn't taste
right until i got back on level playing
field with him it was like it it snapped
something inside of me and so i don't
think you're gonna see something that
extreme here but that's the principle
that's in play so anyway what we're
going to do is we're going to bless you
i want you to to go through financial
peace university
as part of your pre-marriage counseling
and i'm going to pay for it
well thank you so much that means so
much okay and then the two of you are
studying these principles because if you
can come into you know jesus said your
treasure is where your heart is so if
you can come into agreement on your
money
you know even though you're not
combining it we're both talking about it
she's doing the same things you're doing
you're on operating on the same biblical
principles of finance and you're both in
agreement that this is how we're going
to live our lives you have a huge step
up now then whatever money you would
have put through y wham to her or
whatever money you would have paid on
her debt just pile it up
okay and the day you get married and
when you get home from the honeymoon
write a check and pay it off
yeah that's yeah it's the same effect
you're still going to be out of debt at
about the same time actually
uh depending on how much of that 25 she
could have knocked out on
uh donated income
probably not any during the next uh
between now and the next august
very little she's going to reduce it but
if you piled up 25k over there in an
account you come off the honeymoon write
a check boom boom we're done
on to the next baby step and you're
going to be walking your way right
through this it'll change everything
but
there is something
uh there is a reason that jesus talked
so much about money in the new testament
more than he did grace by the way in the
parables there's something powerful
about the the shift when you start
mixing money into relationships
and by the way you're always all of us
are always mixing money into
relationships and so we tell folks be
very careful to keep your money separate
until you are married absolutely but the
thing is is like you said he can still
be sitting money aside setting it aside
for when they do get married the moment
they get married that evening he can go
in and pay off her debt and i just think
it's not that evening you have to wait
till the next day
true
true they'll be busy
come on christina you're not that old
but i will say
[Laughter]
how cool i mean he said he took
foundations five years ago so there may
be what
22-23 yeah they got plenty of time
they got plenty of time
[Laughter]
they're gonna be good you're in good
shape young man hang on we'll get you
signed up for financial peace university
and uh we'll be part of your
pre-marriage counseling this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramseysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual
amazing relationships open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in and we'll make this
happen kirsten is with us in buffalo hi
kirsten welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up
um i just wanted to start off by saying
thank you because actually you inspired
me to go back to church after not going
for a really long time so just thank you
for that um thank you
and also
so i just moved out of my parents house
i'm starting an internship um it's like
my first time being on my own and i have
about two hundred dollars to my name and
i need to just figure out how i'm gonna
like i know
that i need to start a budget but i
guess like what should i
prioritize in my budget and what should
i start first is kind of my question
well congratulations that's good for you
for moving out on your own i know that's
a huge step and it can be super
intimidating doing that the first time i
can instantly feel all these feelings
for the first time i did it so you know
i'm i'm proud of you for getting out
there
now have you been through
have you been through financial peace
no i haven't um
i was considering possibly taking it but
i have just been trying to
honestly like as much as possible went
door dashing earlier today before i
start tomorrow at work so
just trying to get as much cash as
possible and i was just um hoping
to get some practical advice yeah that's
smart what are you what are you going to
be making as an intern
um 18 an hour
when it comes to budgeting we always say
to start with the four walls which are
food utilities shelter and
transportation those are the you know
the things that you need to survive so i
would first start with budgeting that we
have an awesome app called every dollar
are you familiar with every dollar
uh yeah i've heard of it okay well i
want you to download it tonight and
start looking at it it really takes some
of the overwhelm out of budgeting a lot
of people sit down with a spreadsheet
and feel like this is a lot but every
dollar you know it lays it out in a way
that's really easy to understand and
makes it doable now i will warn you when
you first do your budget you're probably
going to feel like you're failing and
you don't know what you're doing we all
feel that way it usually takes everyone
about three months to really
wrap your head around it and kind of get
in a groove but i mean first things
first take for take care of those four
walls and actually start budgeting
because even if it's messy at first even
if it feels overwhelming you will get
there you're getting 40 hours at 18.
yeah um and then the taxes new york
state taxes are kind of brutal yeah um
how much is your rate i'll probably be
more like 14 or something an hour once
taxes come out
i'm gonna budget for that maybe how much
is your rent
so i got into a really cheap living
situation where i'm only paying like two
hundred a month because one of my
friends
let me live in her room okay that's cool
that's a great deal all right do you
have any debt
no
i was very lucky um
that my parents
helped me pay for college and everything
and i
contributed since i was working in high
school yeah well very simplistically
food is first
and that's not eating out that's
groceries
eating out is is luxury
cooking food
is
existence
eating out is eating out is
entertainment
okay so food is first
utilities are you paying utilities or is
it included in your 200
i'm contributing to it we're splitting
it
okay so that's number two
number three is the two hundred dollars
rent
number four is you keep gas in your car
so you can go to work
yep okay
so now let's let's review
you've eaten
you're warm
and there's a roof over your head
and your car will go to work
you kind of got the basics of life
covered then that's the four walls
christina was referring to
so food shelter clothing transportation
utilities these are the basics of life
you probably don't need a lot of
clothing you probably don't need a ton
of food
but you need to budget for those things
first because if you've got that taken
care of your body your mind can relax a
little bit and then once we've survived
we're sustainable we can start thinking
about other goals
but if we start thinking about oh i'm
going to go out every weekend
uh oh i don't have any food in the
cabinet
well that's called being a child
and sometimes 53 year olds are children
so this is just you're asking about
priorities that's how you do it you lay
it all out
and uh how old are you
i'm 20. what are you interning in
i'm a biology a microbiology intern
okay and so did you do a two-year
um no so i'm between my junior and
senior years of height of college
so you have one year left
yeah and your parents are paying for
that year
yes but when i i i have to cover rent by
myself so i'm going to try to save money
beyond that so i can
stay out of the house in my own run okay
good idea i like every bit of this okay
cool
all right so what your goal right now is
is get through school alive
that's about it you don't need a big
financial goal and so i want if you pile
up 50 000 in your bank account to get
through school alive
when you graduate you'll have plenty of
time to do everything else you need to
do
but i just want you to finish i want you
to finish
with no debt
and
reasonable amounts of stress that you
have managed
by prioritizing this
okay so christine is right go download
every dollar get that income coming in
on that internship
she's go-getter yeah that's amazing and
even the fact that she's choosing to
move out and stay stay on her own beyond
um beyond just the first three years of
college and continue on that journey is
just proof of that that's awesome
well and it's like
i was reading an article this weekend uh
that that she chose
she she wanted to do this so badly that
she chose a way to do it that she could
afford in her budget 200 bucks in a room
as a roommate staying in someone's room
absolutely you know
um versus i need a 1 600 square foot
apartment with a skylight and a jacuzzi
and a racquetball court
and oh an indoor garage
and this is and i'm 20.
i mean seriously
we can't afford houses young people
cannot afford houses because they think
they need a granite countertop with 3
200 square feet
and six acres
give me a break
she's proof of the hustle that's it i
mean
maybe when we're just starting maybe it
looks like we're just starting
wow what a shot that's awesome well done
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org budget don't
worry
it's worth it
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsey show
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today it's been proven over and
over again you can crush
your financial personal and professional
goals
whether you want to pay off debt land a
dream job build a better relationship it
can happen our number one best-selling
books and tools are in the ramsey ten
dollar sale to give you the proven plan
on how to knock out these goals but
here's the thing ramsey ten dollar sale
ends today
yeah ten bucks doesn't get you much
anymore but during the ten dollar sale
you can get so much value like the total
money makeover book yeah thousands and
thousands and thousands of dollars in
that paid off with that
millions and millions you want to become
a millionaire check it out the total
money makeover is not not the only thing
you can get on the sale questions for
humans know yourself know your money the
graduate survival guide the get hired
digital course the brand new quick read
the momentum theorem
all proven plans to help you crush your
goals ten dollar sale ends today
at ramseysolutions.com
christina that last caller
i it goes back to that article i was
reading about how no one can afford a
house anymore no one can afford college
anymore no one can afford yes they can
yes they can you can afford a car
the difference is is that we have as a
culture me included have become spoiled
freaking rotten
and we think that if we want something
we should just be able to buy it
period i want to go to that school when
i want to live in that house when
i want to drive that car
we
and all of us have got walked around
acting like that somehow we're entitled
to live in these mcmansions when you're
27 freaking years old or you're entitled
to go to this school just because you
breathe air
and it's just asinine it's ridiculous
and it really it goes back to the thing
we taught for 20 years 25 years that
probably the number one
most powerful financial principle is
contentment
yep well i mean i think as a culture
we're starting to build up certain
things to where people assume they have
to have it you know with college
everybody needs to go to a fancy private
school or at least everybody in your
community might be going so you think
you need to go you know everybody for
young adults you may be seeing all your
friends getting three thousand square
foot homes and think you gotta have it
and it's like you don't really need to
start there you can get there eventually
but that's not where you need to start
and it's kind of crazy seeing what's
happening in the world of college a lot
of these colleges now they're set up
like five-star resorts they've got lazy
rivers they've got these beautiful dorms
with all these amenities like you're
basically staying at a beautiful resort
the freaking ritz carlton
for your 19 year old
to play beer pong in so a lot of people
get out of college and then they think
you know if this is where i lived in
college then i need to upgrade i need to
have a beautiful apartment and a great
location by myself and have all these
amenities and that's just not true and i
just i love that last caller the fact
that she was living with someone in a
room for 200
in new york like that's amazing she
figured out a way to work it out it's
not glamorous you know it's not going to
be the most beautiful luxurious setup
but she was willing to make sacrifices
now so that she could graduate debt-free
and have a great future
now i sold them
in 30 years abruptly in the call
but if i get someone that calls in and
it's like well you know you've got these
two 700 car payments
these escalades have got to go i mean
this is ridiculous you all have lost
your minds here and you've got to get
rid of these escalates i can't get rid
of escalade
yeah you don't really have a choice no
we'll have to have to work on something
else i can't sell the escalade pop
you're gone i'm done dealing with you
i'm not trying i'm not going to try to
talk you in past that once you're that
obstinate and you're that stuck on
driving an escalade
you're not ready for me to help you
because i can't really help you you're
gonna have to go i'll drive anything
i'll do anything i'll work anywhere that
is legal and moral i will do whatever it
takes i have had it i'm sick and tired
of being sick and tired i'm ready to
change my life and i'm not going you
know five million dollars in debt to get
a degree in left-handed puppetry from
some famous stinking school with a lazy
river this is just ridiculous right it's
ridiculous it's how we got to this epic
student loan crisis and the stupid
government just keeps writing these
checks writing these checks why because
the government is stupid
they're just straight up stupid they
have no off button i had a little pug
dog and that dog we could not put food
out
because whatever food we put out it ate
it it did not have an off button for
food and that's congress it does not
have an off button it will eat it until
it just explodes
the little dog would get so fat that we
had to just quit feeding it it was you
know and congress is the same thing
they're just fat it's ridiculous it's
all off of you people me well i think
that's what's so hard with a student
loan crisis right now and all this talk
about student loan forgiveness and if
it's going to happen if it's not going
to happen i think so many people are
wondering you know if it does happen
then are we changing the way
that college works like are we going to
make college cheaper now like how do we
prevent then the next generation from
falling into the exact same trap
you know like we want student loan
relief we want people to
have freedom from their student loans we
want them to pay off debt but we also
want to prevent the future generation
from walking off the same cliff
yeah what's the purpose of saving this
bunch are you gonna turn and save the
next bunch right you gotta quit making
the stupid loans and it's
it's intellectual dishonesty to keep
making loans while you talk about
forgiving them because they're so evil
and it needs to stop and he says stop
but it all comes down to
this sense of entitlement arrogance
versus a sense of of contentment and
that was what was so beautiful about her
that's what brought this up coming out
of that break was uh you know you said
hey let's talk about these colleges and
how they're out of control because she
chose a school she can afford a living
situation she can afford a work
situation that would make it work she's
finding her way
right through it you know absolutely and
i think that's the thing is like we have
to make going to college debt-free cool
like we got to fight this culture that
at whatever expense at whatever cost you
got to go to the big prestigious school
with the you know fancy ranking like if
you can do that and you get scholarships
to do it if you get financial aid to do
it that is awesome but if it costs you
the next 10 years of your life
that's not worth it it's just not worth
it you know and we walk around ramsey
solutions you know we're super
competitive workplace it's hard to get a
job here it's really competitive but
when you walk around you'll see people
who went to community college you'll see
people who maybe didn't get go to
college and they just hustled really
hard and learned a certain skill you
know you'll see people who went to ivy
leagues and we're all working in the
same workplace together and we all have
to get our job done it's just the same
go figure who knew
so there it is our question today comes
from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best possible deal
today's question comes from andy in
south dakota i was planning to go into
the military and using the gi bill to
pay for college i just learned that i
was not accepted due to an undiagnosed
medical issue
what do i do now
well first off andy i'm so sorry about
that i know that can be kind of
surprising and overwhelming um but what
a lot of people don't understand with
the military and the application and if
you get medically disqualified is that
one it may not be a permanent
disqualification and two even if it is
technically a permanent disqualification
you may be able to get a waiver for from
a doctor for that condition so i would
definitely dig deeper and explore
farther and also you could possibly
apply to different branches of the
military so if you've been rejected from
the army for example you could still
apply to the navy marine corps air force
or coast guard
you just or you could even look at a
different geographic location so again
dig a little deeper
you may qualify with a medical condition
if you can talk to a doctor and figure
out if there's a workaround with that
and you may not but you won't know until
you really talk to different recruiters
and dig a little deeper to see what's
available i would also check with the
national guard they will pay almost as
much of your college as the gi bill will
and it's an absolutely incredible
benefit package and you get to work on a
full-time job too
so a national guard is a is a good gig
and so a lot of people doing that and
going that direction as well to get
through there of course the other thing
is take two steps back unless okay how
do we how do we skin this cat poor cats
are always getting skinned how do we
skin this cat
and what are we gonna do next and okay
let's figure out a way over we're going
to this school over here i'm going to
work this job yeah and the military's
just not in your future and i hope it is
if you your desire to serve and you're
coming out of memorial day we appreciate
your desire to serve thank you we honor
that
but if that's not in the cards
what's god got for you there's another
thing
it sure wouldn't to stop where you are
it's just a it's a detour dude turn left
turn right go
foot back on the gas kick it in gear
spin around the corner course correct go
this is the ramsey
[Music]
so
[Music]
christina alice ramsey personality is my
co-host today we're in the lobby of
ramsey solutions drop by and watch the
show hang out with us anytime on the
debt-free stage right here in the lobby
live is brandon and cassie hey guys how
are y'all well you're doing great
welcome welcome where do you guys live
uh south side of denver colorado welcome
to nashville that's a bit of a haul
across the continental divide well not
sort of but not quite but close yeah
good to have you guys all right how much
debt have you paid off a little over 621
thousand dollars
how long did this take
uh just under nine years good eight
years and eleven months wow and your
range of income during that nine years
uh we had some years that we were in the
low 200s and we've had a couple years
where we've uh we've gotten really close
to 300. okay cool what do y'all do for a
living
i'm a family physician
and i'm a mechanical engineer in the oil
and gas industry oh wow okay well lots
going on
excellent so i'm gonna guess with that
length of time and that amount of money
maybe you paid off your house sure did i
love it looking at weird people
way to go you guys all right nine years
is a long journey tell us about the
story what in the world true story it's
uh it is a long time
um we uh we were struggling with like
the time as most people would over nine
years
um one of the things that we did was uh
we ended up leading four fpu classes
um throughout the process and that was
one of the things that we did just kind
of keep motivated and it was it was a
struggle as you can imagine yeah that's
real but that that if you're teaching it
it's really difficult to be hypocritical
and go back on it yeah oh yeah
absolutely what got this whole thing
started
i wanted to get rid of the debt the
minute that i've graduated from medical
school it always was really emotional
for me to be that far in debt um and it
took a little bit longer until brandon
found your principles and
your ideas on on how to actually do it
rather than just you know you hear all
the other financial people that say just
invest invest invest you'll make more
money and
obviously got to do it in a weird way
and stuff so constant nagging not really
[Laughter]
that works so the 621 was all the
mortgage not medical school it was both
um about 220 of it
was medical school and that was just the
principle on it that didn't include any
interest i have no idea how much we paid
in interest over that period of time too
much and then yeah and then uh 400 of it
was the house and you know per typical
over the last couple years a house is
now worth like 9.75 so oh wow um denver
market's been good in the last couple
years and you've been investing
yeah so you're you're everyday
millionaires your baby steps
millionaires yeah we're we're up to
about 1.6 right now
you guys so proud of you thank you yeah
and you have no debt in the world none
how's that feel it's amazing i'd highly
recommend it actually
it didn't kind of hit me until we got
here today oh wow like it it really hit
me
being here today wow yeah what would you
tell people is the key to getting out of
debt
oh my gosh um
perseverance through time for us
and and having a common goal like
you can't
she couldn't do it on her own clearly
that's the
you know continual talks to motivate her
stupid husband
to to get going but uh once we got on
the same page it
it didn't fly by any means like there
were a lot of times where like hey you
know it would be really cool to buy a
nicer car or go on the trip or do this
and and you just kind of wait and you
you don't
but uh as long as you're on the same
page it works i need to get the family
involved our kids have heard about
budgets
for since they were itty bitty's they
they will know oh is that not in the
budget nope nope it really isn't guys
what a legacy to leave too that's
amazing like the next generation is
already learning the principles and
they're going to be set up for success
from the very beginning absolutely that
is awesome so you guys have obviously
led financial peace classes you've seen
a lot of people come in and you know
they're at the very beginning what would
you tell someone who thinks paying off a
house wow i could never do that that's
weird like what would you tell them when
they're starting their journey
so
you wanna i'll go so
kind of what dave was saying here about
10 minutes ago your your lifestyle is
key like what is the house like
is the house a place where you raise
your kids and have a home or is it some
seven thousand square foot building on
the top of the hill like
that matters a lot and and what's what's
important to you
and what's going to be the thing that's
motivating for you so for us
we kept the house that we've lived in
we've been there about 10 years now
and
um we looked around and we chose to do a
remodel and knock down some halls and
redo the kitchen and stay there because
we really like our neighborhood and cash
flow of that cash flow that's a process
too
yeah so
um
it's been good but yeah it's
it's a lot i'd also say just get started
like you don't know
when we first started the amount that we
were in debt just felt insurmountable it
felt really emotional like i said and so
just even just getting started and
thinking we're never going to get to the
end it really did feel that way but then
just seeing each month by month by month
see that the debt goes down and brandon
likes to track the net worth he thinks
that that's more
you know inspiring is to watch your net
worth go up since it was a zero to begin
with or negative to begin with um to
watch that go up was was motivating but
just continuing to look and focus on
what your goal is yeah that's awesome
how old are you guys
41.
and you're worth 1.6 and you have a paid
for house just outside of denver and
you're making two three hundred thousand
a year you can do anything you wanna do
so you were 31 years old you're staring
at this mountain
in front of you
um
and cassie you said it really didn't hit
you you walked in here that's fun i like
that but
what's what's that feeling because
there's other people staring at that
mountain and i want them to hear what
the feeling is when you're on top of it
when you've gone over the top of it
relief
there's a lot of relief a lot of joy a
lot of looking at these kids and knowing
that
i mean we've already watched the
documentary about student loan and
talking about what that that future is
for them and just like you say it's a
legacy that we're leaving
and there's a lot of pride i think in
that as well
yeah there's a sense of uh
release almost oh for sure yeah way to
go you guys all right what's the first
big thing you're gonna do you gotta do
something fun now the remodel but what
else yeah we figured we'd cashflow a
trip to nashville
big spender now we've got a we've got a
we're probably going to get a hot tub
here in the fall and that's kind of the
next thing i know that's for the house
so a little splurge nice yeah that's fun
that's awesome who are you who are your
biggest cheerleaders in the process
because that's that's a long journey you
need a good community around you yeah go
ahead on that
we didn't really tell a lot of people no
in terms of
the numbers um we talked about it over
time and everybody was encouraging
about
about where to go and so on and so forth
but uh
i mean my parents just found out how
much we made on this show so
that's pretty much our story on that
sure they are proud
i think that there's a lot of people who
were just generally encouraging but
unless you're going through it unless
you understand what we're doing which a
lot of people didn't
yeah it's not the same and so i think i
think there was a lot of encouragement
back and forth between us yeah for sure
but it's a it's a it's a concept like
you said unless somebody's plugged in
they don't they don't get it
we also heard the um
you know the few times that we try and
open up the well of course you can do
you make a quarter million dollars and
you're like that's that's a lot of
that's a lot of tech guys
that's so hard i like to point out that
like my student loans were twice my
yearly income so if people want to put
it in that process because they're like
well you make a lot of money yeah but i
my debt my student loans coming out were
twice my yearly income starting out when
i got my first job at 29. wow wow
well here we are you did it we've got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
because that's obviously who you are
congratulations a copy of total money
makeover you can give them both away
read them both whatever you want to do
also a one-year subscription to
financial peace university ramsey plus
and uh you'll be able to give that away
to somebody for sure as coordinators all
this time so very well done thank you
for leading the classes too we really
appreciate it inspiring inspiring people
very very very well done good stuff all
right it's brandon and cassie and the
kiddos names and ages we got bj at 13
and annika attended all right let's
count it down and hear a debt-free
scream 621 000 paid off in nine years
house and everything
making two to three hundred count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
one two three
[Applause]
[Music]
and we're 41 and worth almost 2 million
dollars amazing
but the ramsey organization just tells
people get out of debt we don't know
anything about building wealth here just
for those of you that have heard
stupid butt stuff on reddit
there's millionaires on these stages
every week
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today dylan is with us
dylan is in fort worth texas hi dylan
how can we help today
hey dave i have to ask how are you doing
today better than i deserve well great
to hear that so i'll try to just break
down a little background for you so i am
31 i'm a personal trainer in fort worth
um last year made probably about 84
gross income and i'm getting kind of
pulled into over the last few years
thinking about changing careers
so i've been doing this for about 12
years
and over the last few years of course
with covid everything like that
i was with a big big corporate gym for
about five years and upon coming back i
was basically eliminated so
i went back on my own been doing that
since 2020
and pretty do pretty well on income
schedule wise work life balance is great
um although i do feel like i am just
kind of going through the motions rather
than thriving so i didn't know if it was
quite time for for a change i've been
approached by a past client's husband a
couple of times
to go do some business
sales for a technology company
so of course sales has been something
i've been in my whole life
but it's always been selling myself and
selling results rather than a product
and service um so i just kind of want to
get your feedback on that i am a
divorced last year
currently just lived me and my son half
the time and
i don't know just make sure i don't have
a heart attack on the phone
i think you're gonna be okay
oh my goodness
well um
i don't hear a lot of um
there's not like a lot of excitement
about anything in the conversation
okay
like i'm not excited about where i am
and i don't hear anything about where
you're going that's exciting somewhere
somewhere i need to get some excitement
in the conversation again
i definitely love what i do i've done it
for so long though over time it does get
a bit a bit tedious and repetitive and
you know dealing with with clients
things like that but i love the
relationships that i've built that's
always something i have
exerted on to resumes or if i ever did
get called in for some sort of interview
was that relationship building process
is crucial for me and that's how i've
always built my business
it was never really just that oh i'm the
guy that's going to make you lose 20
pounds
so it's the same thing same thing for
you as people
people rely on your processes and your
systems not just hearing you talk on the
radio right so and hearing your team you
know giving their input and things like
that so it's it's i've had a gathered
input on the same
question but it's all people that know
me personally yeah i mean that's what
that's exactly what ken coleman would
tell you to do and i would agree with
that so you're gathering up what what
what it is that what are your drivers
but then the application of that so far
that i heard was
uh
i've got a client's husband who says i
can sell for him that didn't make you
jump up and down for glee the way you
said it
i think so that first conversation with
him was probably about four years ago
they approached me last fall i went
through the interview process got to the
last interview
which would have been with with him the
guy under him which would be the direct
lead and then the person above both of
them so i kind of pulled my name out of
the hat i think at the time i was
just finalizing some some divorce and
working on myself and making sure that
things were going to be good for my son
and i and i didn't feel like it was
really a good time for a change
so
upon that they approached me a few weeks
ago and you know said that the the
territory you could say is now exactly
where i live
um so i think just kind of the
excitement of feeling
wanted and feeling like oh i've been
approached
by something completely out of my realm
by people that feel that i could do it
and be successful at it dylan if you
could do if you could do anything what
would you do like whether it's personal
training or sales if you could even do
something outside of that what would you
do i think i want to do something that's
relationship driven that i'm able to
make a great income at be able to have a
flexible schedule
um still be able to but not have to have
that worry of
am i going to get paid this week or is
someone going to skip this week and then
not abide by
their agreement or not abide by their
cancellation
so that it's always the wishy-washiness
of my industry is our schedules and our
income yeah especially when you're
self-employed it's it's outrageous the
amount of just
that hill and valley fund you're always
talking about
you have to have it okay so the new gig
what does the new gig pay
um so what i've been told so far is
about 50 which is upper debate with hr
um so that hasn't been told to me
exactly yet based on my qualifications
education etc
and then commissions so what i did
towards the beginning is i wanted to
talk with his best performer
who was making at the time gonna make
about 150 to 200 and his worst performer
who was almost exiting the team was
still going to be around 110. um so i
tried to do my due diligence and making
sure that i was speaking with the best
and the worst of course i didn't speak
with the worst
um but i wanted to know okay what's
what's my actual average when it comes
to this this treasure you make now
um last year was about 84 gross okay so
you make 100 minimum you got an increase
it's a new thing
it's a new life after a divorce you're
starting fresh
i think you do it i don't see any
downside there's nothing
there's nothing here you're telling me
there's you're not telling me anything
on the list that's negative
um i just was not hearing the excitement
and the more you talked about it i
started hearing some excitement
i think just the only negative is is the
change and then the unknown of okay is
that boat actually close enough to the
dock to make that kind of jump and is my
financial situation capable of that um
about
65 000 student loans
to go along with y'all's rant a few
minutes ago
um so that has basically been stagnant
for a few years um i have about that
wasn't due to income that was due to a
divorce
everything was stagnant for the last two
years
yes everything's been pretty much at a
standstill since i left um the big gym
so um got consumer debt got stupid debt
taken care of but it's all stupid but of
course
you can live on the 50
barely you for sure can live on the 100.
definitely yeah
and i even played with a couple of
months ago to to sell the house mortgage
payments about 1700 now because i had to
do a cash out
um and pay off that half of the equity
so i had even wondered if that if it's
even
do i jump jump on the wave of selling
but then i had looked at rentals and
things like that rentals in our area are
about 2 000 2500
um of course not including deposits all
that but that was another thought as
well but i wasn't going to really
include that question yeah it's fine i
mean i think you take it and
you know if it if you need to sell the
house a little bit later you still can
do that i don't think the market's going
to drop in the next 20 minutes
um you're going to be fine yeah i if
it's if i'm in your shoes i'm giving the
thing a run
um but this is uh
you go through a divorce and you're
going through this there's a lot of
holding your breath and this feels like
an exhale
game on
new direction fresh start whiteboard
new beginnings yeah and don't stay on
the line we're going to gift you a copy
of
our book from ken coleman one of our
colleagues from paycheck to purpose
it'll answer a lot of those questions
that you're having and kind of help you
find that motivation and that
inspiration within the role that you
have and also there's a get clear
assessment which will give you access to
that just to make sure that you're clear
on what you want to do and that you're
really on the right path moving forward
now one of the things i'm poking around
on and i think i got there i felt like i
got there was
and this is for the rest of your
listening of course is when you go
through a major transition
like a divorce
or the loss of a loved one or something
like that
and then a job change comes right beside
it
that's a little bit of a warning
be careful alarms are going off because
you might be trying to fix some wounds
with this other thing but it did the
more i talked with him more i felt like
we got the other side of that that this
is instead of a fixing the wounds it was
more like a fresh start
and so it felt it felt
to me felt fine so but
probably worth what you paid for it
anyway there you go
hang on we'll get you a copy of ken's
book
that puts us out of the ramsey show in
the books thanks to austin ben zak
andrew and james in the booth i am dave
ramsey and we'll be back
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the ramsey show we help people
build wealth
we help them find and do work that they
love and that matters we help them
create amazing actual
relationships christina ellis number one
best-selling author and ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money riley is going to start
off this hour in minneapolis hi riley
welcome to the ramsey show
good afternoon mr ramsey good afternoon
mrs ellis thank you very much for having
me on the show today our honor sir how
many how may we help
uh i just wanted to start by saying
thank you for all that you and your team
do
we're very fortunate to have you around
here in the united states and all over
the world listening to how you help
people thank you essentially my
absolutely essentially my question today
is
uh is this i'm missing anything i am
currently investing 20 my 401k
through my employer i'm currently maxing
out my roth ira
i am currently doing monthly
distributions
to mutual funds as well as a house fund
that i have set up
into into a fidelity 500 index fund
based on the s p 500 index
in addition to a couple more
high dividend yield stocks and i really
just want to ensure that i'm doing
everything i can to set myself up
for the ability to live and give like no
one else in the future
wow i'm going to be off friday you want
to fill in
i sure wish i
died i mean you got this you got this
down dude you got it so dialed in how
old did you say you are
i am 23 years old what do you make
i make between 60 and 70 000 my main job
40 hours a week i'm making just over 61
and then my side house so i do about 15
to 20 hours a week
make 14 an hour plus tips
how did you learn to do all this by the
time you're 23
i had some fantastic leaders growing up
through sports and a father that worked
extremely hard uh dropped out of college
at 18 has been working for the same
company for 35 years and taught me how
to work hard and be consistent and not
be a good person wow
good for you
pretty amazing well
you're
you're single 23 you make 70 you're
putting all your money in
investments right now and you're saving
towards the house and you're 100 debt
free i don't i don't have anything to
add to this equation you're heading in
the right direction now the next thing
that'll happen usually is you do buy the
house and then we'll be about the
business of getting it paid off as soon
as possible after that
and you know you're gonna and you'll
back your investments down to 15 of your
income at that point until you get that
done but
i don't i don't see any flaws right here
well what's the timeline for when you
want to buy the house what's kind of the
goal you've set for yourself
so i want to move out of my house and
actually move
to the nashville area or somewhere a
little warmer from minneapolis within
the next three years with my company and
then
because of the company and the nature of
the business i'm in uh probably be
moving around quite often so i was
thinking renting for the next probably
10 years until i settled down in a place
that i might be longer than five years
and then uh get a 15-year mortgage and
try to pay it off in five
yeah so you're thinking about moving in
three years and then buying in ten years
yes ma'am okay so you've got time to
save up that down payment i mean it's
time yes ma'am
i currently have a little over 30 000
saved up for the house or renting funds
essentially because i
didn't spend my entire
fun for college i graduated a year early
yeah if you're careful when you make
your move
even if you're not going to be there by
two or three years since you're going to
be paying cash for the property
you may want to look at going and buying
earlier than that 10 year mark but i
mean it
somehow i got a feeling this is not
going to unfold exactly the way you've
got it lined out there
you know um
you know you get married it could change
this equation as an example um like
where you land how often you move
what you do all those kinds of things
are affected then so
uh
that's what i would look at but i think
you've got a great start i don't see
anything wrong with the direction you're
going for the next 24 36 months
just keep rocking it man i mean really i
don't have any fixes to this make sure
you're being generous
make sure you're enjoying your money
don't nerd out on every penny
okay so you need to have some enjoyment
and if those are not muscles you use
very often they can get atrophied so
force yourself in your budget i'm going
to blow
this much money i'm going to be
outrageously generous with this much
money
and uh force yourself into those
muscle groups but
um it's not you know it's not that hard
i think you can do it you're pretty
incredible what a rock star 23 years old
that's how it's done why did we find
these people zach is in franklin
tennessee hi zach how are you
i'm doing well how are you better than
we deserve sir how can we help
yeah so i'm just kind of wanting to get
some guidance on where to get started
and make sure i don't screw things up
with my money
i just graduated college a couple weeks
ago and i moved into my first full-time
job
congratulations what are you what are
you doing
software consulting oh wow how much
you're making
i'm only making 75 base
and then i'm not sure how much i'm bonus
so i'm just going to say 75 for now good
for you well done
that's awesome thank you do you have any
student debt i do i have about 20 to 22
000 i don't know the exact number off
the top of my head
in student loans and then i have eight
thousand dollars in credit card debt
okay are you familiar with the baby
steps
uh yeah i am i kind of sped red through
the total money makeover but i obviously
didn't uh read it closely enough so i'm
gonna have to
uh you know reread that maybe yeah well
you right now you're in baby step two
which is where you pay off all your debt
and you've got a great shovel right now
75k income just starting out plus
bonuses so right now we want you to get
super intense gazelle intense about
paying off this debt you know the good
thing is is you're just out of college
so you're used to living on beans and
rice and being broke so i want you to
stay that way as you start to attack
this 30 000 in debt
the temptation is when you get the big
job to do something stupid like go buy a
new car don't do that
yeah and that's my problem because i've
only ever worked part-time you know
hourly wages so i've never had a salary
like this so i'm just trying to make
sure i don't do so you feel like it
feels emotionally like you hit the
lottery
yeah pretty much yeah so and you didn't
it's not that much it'll go fast you can
blow it believe me so if you'll do what
christina said and keep living like a
college student you could be 100
debt-free in 12 months
all right that sounds awesome that's i
was kind of wanting to get what you
thought a timeline would be for that
because i'm you know
well i put 30 000 i put 30 000 into 72
plus bonuses
okay and i took out a college student's
lifestyle and you can make it
okay yeah that sounds good that sounds
great yeah that's how i did it i mean it
really wasn't big math it wasn't a
sophisticated formula i used
uh 72 minus 30 leaves me 42
and you're gonna get more than 72
because you got bonuses because you're
sharp you're going to get it done
so yeah go make some money live on
nothing be 100 debt free and that will
catapult you in your wealth building and
into a sense of control and power you've
got over your money
so very well done zach hang on got a
copy of uh
baby steps millionaires as our
graduation gift for you show you how to
be a millionaire this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage scott
and stephanie are with us hey guys how
are you dave it's an honor so great to
be here honored to have you where do you
live
western north carolina cool welcome to
nashville how much debt have you paid
off
215 000
way to go
how long did this take you
five five years
five years and your range of income
during that time around 170. cool what
do you all do for a living
finance in the insurance industry okay
both of you we do yeah we work for the
same company okay good for you fun what
kind of debt was the 215 000 mortgages
our house you paid off your house we did
dave look at it where people i know
way to go you guys very cool what's this
house worth
uh right now it's about 400 thousand
yeah i love it how old are you two
forty eight forty ever paid for house we
do
and we started the journey 2011 with you
when we first got married because we
didn't want to be the couple that fought
about
money
it took us two years to get out of debt
and then we lived debt-free all the way
up until we moved from colorado to
western north carolina and bought our
house wow way to go we've been with you
for a long time yeah yeah 10 years plus
now 11 yeah that's right we're used to
seeing you up on the projector screen at
the church oh back in the day yeah in
the day exactly it's a 100 book and
cds and
it's a fantastic fantastic
classes that we had well thank you
very cool well i'm proud of you guys
well done yes how does it feel to not
have a payment in the world
very free incredible
so tell us about the journey what'd you
all do to get out of debt
well we we stuck to a budget of course
and then we
we pretty much did gazelled our house to
be honest with you and it took a few
years to do that
so we just put everything towards our
mortgage
every month we had residual about eight
or nine thousand dollars we put towards
the house every month wow paid off just
knock it down knock it down knock it
down five years later you're done we're
done exactly you can feel the enthusiasm
with you guys like it can just like
seeing you through the glass it's like
whoa i can feel the energy it's amazing
what would you tell people is the key to
getting out of debt
being on the same page being on the same
page i mean 10 years ago
when not we've been married a little bit
longer than 10 years but we said we did
not want to be that couple that fought
about money
we will not be that statistic and so
that's when we were introduced to fpu
okay and we never looked back
and so those people that are out there
that may be thinking of doing the same
thing just do it just just do it make
sure you have a great partner to be on
your side as well because it takes two
people yeah
and just do it you know we had a lot of
people we would say we're about to pay
off our house and they'll say well why
would you want to why would you want to
do that why did you do that why wouldn't
i yeah
and so our you know you always say who
is your biggest cheerleader each other
you're each other's cheerleader yeah
for sure that's so good well i hope
people on the other line can catch some
of that enthusiasm because that's just
that's incredible that's just so
powerful um so now what you're
completely debt-free what are you going
to do next
well we
we're continuing our investments you
know exactly as we have been
you know 15 percent and even more
putting towards you know everything
you've taught us well you ought to be
able to go do something big what are you
going to do to celebrate
italy the olympics italy all right now
we're getting down to it that's right
all right that's a good trip but first
we're going to pay off our our gas bill
of driving here
gas prices
well maybe biden will pay it off for you
maybe i don't count on it i wouldn't
hold my breath
very good you guys very good yeah we
live in a beautiful place in the smoky
mountains so it's really we're just
gonna enjoy where we live and what we do
and
and uh you know just be appreciative of
the journey and yeah love everything
we've built for each other so uh how are
the investments going what are they up
to
well they're
they're
about 100 something thousand dollars
okay so you're about three years from
being baby steps millionaires then yeah
yeah way to go but what we gazelled the
house the amount that we could sell the
house with we're going to start to do
the same thing with our investments so
it's going to be might be two years
there might be two years then yes yeah
good
very good guys that's fun it's you guys
are impressive thank you i'm sorry man
being here i just can't even
emotional it's like the previous
debt-free screamers that were here and
they said it didn't really hit them till
they walked in the booth
same thing i don't think i've been this
excited since our wedding day i mean oh
my gosh yes yeah just
it's remarkable yeah can you explain how
that feels for the people who are you
know at the beginning who are feeling
the weight and the struggle of having
debt can you explain just how good it
feels to be standing there today i'm
doing everything i can to not break out
in tears right now
you get to make different decisions with
your life you get to make different
decisions as a couple when you don't
have to worry about your money going
towards
other things and other people when you
don't owe other people you just get to
make different elevated decisions as a
couple that you may not get to make
otherwise and so it's very freeing
and the world is your oyster amen
well you got 170 000 coming in and
nobody on the hook that's right nobody's
owed a thing you can do whatever you
want to do now that's right italy you
can you can do all kinds of stuff way to
go you guys
very very proud of you you are very
impressive yes are you how are you sir
honor honored to meet you honored to
meet you good stuff we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you because
that is the next chapter and as we said
that's about uh two years off probably
something like that
we've got another uh one-year
subscription to financial peace
university you can give that away pay it
forward to somebody i'm sure you know
somebody needs to share it it's been
inspired by your story and needs to do
what you've done same thing with the
total money makeover book we'll give you
we'll give you lots of stuff to give
away so you can pass it along and and
celebrate this and we're so proud of you
guys you're an amazing couple very well
done yeah thank you so much are you sir
thank you very much very cool scott and
stephanie from north carolina 215 000
paid off house and everything
looking at weird people they did this in
five years making 170 count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one we're debt-free
this is how it's done ladies and
gentlemen
well done
oh man
it is emotional to work five years to
get to do something and then get to do
it yeah that is emotional
and now i hear that i mean to do the
debt free screen but that free screen
really doesn't mean anything it's what
means something is the fact that you're
there and it's the celebration of all
the hard work all the sacrifice and by
god winning you know just winning ring
the bell yeah goodness i almost teared
up just watching them out there just
seeing all that emotion it's like all
their hard work all their sacrifice all
the putting off things you know for now
so that they can be in this moment in
this moment it's just like woo you could
just feel it pretty incredible beautiful
family very very well done you guys
that's uh powerful stuff so what do you
do
uh you have to pay attention
and most people just don't
they've been paying attention for five
years
longer really he said it started back in
2011 they worked through their
other debts and so
the typical baby steps millionaires that
we have studied
his debt free house and everything in
about 10.2 years
so there they are
2011 to now that's about 11 years right
so there we are
uh the typical is about 51 years old
they're a little younger than that
so they're pretty typical on where they
are they're not quite the millionaire
though so
uh but they'll be there before they're
50.
and
it just can be done it can be done don't
let people
tell you that the government's going to
do it for you they're not they're stupid
don't let people tell you that uh your
your company that you work for is going
to do it for you they're not they're
stupid
you're in control of your life thank god
you're in control of your life you're
the best shot you have at winning in
your life
you get to decide you're in control
yes there's things outside of your
control there's
crazy people out there there's
people that don't behave the way they're
supposed to behave there's all kinds of
things you run into that's part of the
equation
but you're in control of you
and whether 10 years from now you're
winning or not
is 98
in your control
it's up to you
so you gonna do it or not
are you going to do it or not
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
well occasionally here in the studios a
good friend drops by
senator marsha blackburn has uh
been a good personal friend she and
chuck are friends of
sharon and i for gosh 25 almost 30 years
now
something like that we're getting old
long before you long before you were a
senator and long before there were three
people listening to this radio show so i
was only in tennessee back in those days
but a lot of water under the bridge and
uh i don't want to take a bunch of time
going down memory lane or anything i
want to get straight to it you guys uh
you and rick scott and a couple of other
senators have put forth a bill and you
told me you wanted to come by and talk
about it to stop
the spending in the middle of inflation
spending while we're in inflation just
doesn't make sense mathematically
you're right about that because what are
we doing we're borrowing money
from china
to
spend on programs that are going to
outlive their usefulness by the time our
kids and grandkids have to pay the bill
so it doesn't make any sense so
my legislation is very simple
it says that during times of high
inflation which is defined in
statute as four percent or greater
during those times of high inflation if
you want to pass a spending bill you
have to do it with a two-thirds majority
that makes sense that means that
whatever you're going to spend money on
then two-thirds of the members of the
senate in the house have to agree that
this is a worthy endeavor
and good use of the taxpayer dollar
because it's not congress's money the
president's money the bureaucracy's
money
it is the people's money
yeah and the problem is
if you're going to spend money to
stimulate an economy where there's
already a shortage
of things causing prices to increase
that's right you're going to so much
money chasing too few goods you're going
to make it worse that's exactly the
wrong time it seems to me i
you don't have to be a politician left
or right and you don't really have to
even
you certainly don't have to be an
economist you just kind of have to have
some basic common sense that's right and
this is one of those common sense
measures this makes sense to everybody
that
if
you are
it doesn't make sense to some of my
friends across the aisle of course or
those that are big spenders but it just
says you can't do this you know take for
instance covid 6.8 trillion dollars
biden's pushed out the door
on a covid and wants another 2 trillion
for
another budget and you can read j.p
morgan or morgan stanley's report what
do they say has been a major
contributing factor to inflation
biden bucks that's right
biden bucks that's exactly right
so because it's disrupted the labor
market i mean i've said this on fox i've
said that on here as well i mean there's
three components to me to this
inflationary market right now there's
the energy component the cost of gas
that's a hundred percent on joe biden's
desk there's the disruption of the
supply chain
and then when we shut down the factories
that's not his fault but he is living in
that reality and he could do some things
to smooth it out but that one's not on
him and then there's the disruption of
the labor market which is about 75 on
him that's right because he screwed the
labor market up which you know by the
way that loaf of bread going up the
reason it went up is we pay a guy thirty
dollars an hour to put that loaf of
bread on the shelves now we used to pay
him ten dollars an hour and that's the
disruption the labor market when you pay
people not to work magically they won't
work that's right and then the the cost
of all the supplies going into that loaf
of bread costs more same thing has
happened with coffee coffee's up 143
percent eggs are up 50 percent you look
at all of these having trouble getting
out of breakfast
[Laughter]
and you you're here at the beginning of
the day and you've got to go all the way
till you turn the lights off
and the price at the pump here's another
thing if biden wanted to really do
something to help our european allies
and to help with inflation
start the energy market back up he has
passed it back on that's right he has
put 69 regulations on the books major
regulations since he took office most of
those are aimed at the energy market now
by comparison during donald trump's
four years across the board he did a
total of 22
major regulations but he took
1600
off the books his first year
but let's get the energy market going
because the hydrocarbons the polymers
that come from that
that affect all of the wrapping that
your food goes into the plastic bags
polyester the clothes you wear synthetic
fabrics shoes you name it in addition to
the cost to drive the car heat and cool
the house tires that go on that car all
of this is suffering because of what joe
biden did on day one
to begin to adversely impact the energy
market yeah the energy the energy thing
there's no question that's on his i mean
that's a yeah that's a turn that's a
switch he turned on can turn off back
and forth the others is a little harder
for him to manipulate you can't get the
genie back in the bottle on the biden
bucks don't do it again but you can't
get it back in the bottle that's
disrupted and it's throwing this labor
mark at a skew and you know we've got
entire industries are having trouble
operating from a lever a labor shortage
at this point
which is driving the cost of labor up
which is driving inflation and that is a
result of that now again the shutting
down a factory for six months uh you can
blame that on fouchy you can blame it on
covid you can blame it on the economic
suppression loss of freedom we talk
about all kinds of things there but
that's the the earthquake at sea the
tsunami is the resulting shortages that
came in afterwards
and you know we've got a you know i'm
building this building up here on the
hill and i've got my steel went up 3x on
the building or i was going to i
pre-purchased it so it didn't
but uh i mean we saw it coming but the
all the you know and that's driving the
housing market all these things are
layering in there i guess the other one
to add to it there's a fourth component
and tell me what you're thinking about
what the fed's doing with these interest
rates
and what the fed is trying to do is get
in here and cover up mistakes
and so
you know i i think that um they don't
want to admit that um
that binomics is not working
and they don't want to admit
that people are not going
back to work i've been in four tennessee
counties today and dave every one of
these county mayors have said we don't
have enough people to fill the jobs that
are everywhere
in this county
right and you know i i think that uh
when you listen to people like janet
yellen what do you hear her say
that the economy is doing great and
they've created all these jobs no people
are going back to the jobs that they had
and that they left during covid
and they haven't created all these new
jobs
so
um the economy's not expanding that's
the only way you could have new jobs
that's right we have a recession a
contraction of the economy it appears
we're going to have a a second quarter
of a contraction and it's not a the
boogie man the recession's coming it's
not that too bad
it does appear we're going to have a
recession maybe light and maybe just
those two quarters but uh we're pretty
much pretty much going to be down again
on gdp i think that's what all the
indicators i'm reading are so uh but
that that does not indicate no jobs that
does not indicate a booming economy
quite it's a shrinking economy a
contract that's the very meaning of the
word recession yeah you're right and you
know it's just as you said simple
economics when you have too much money
in pursuit of too few goods what's going
to happen
the price goes up i can't let you go
without 30 seconds
on student loan forgiveness you know we
hate the idea around here while we're
still making the loans do you see any
future where we quit making those loans
i have said repeatedly that one of the
big mistakes that obama made
was federalizing student loans and
bringing it all in house taking it away
from your local community bank
because
the rate double the interest rate
doubled the complexity the invasion of
privacy
the federal government needs to be out
of the student loan business any chance
that that gets through the senate
i would hope so a new day's coming
well there's going to be a lot of stuff
happening after fall i suspect
senator marsha blackburn senator of
tennessee first lady senator of
tennessee our honor to call you friend
and honor to have you as our senator
thanks for stopping by be here thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day psalm 37 23 and
24 the steps of a man are established by
the lord when he delights in his way
though he fall he shall not be cast head
long for the lord upholds his hand
nelson mandela said do not judge me by
my success judge me by how many times i
fell down and got back up again amen to
that
inflation is affecting everyone as we
were just discussing from the gas pump
to the grocery store while you can't
control what happens with the economy
you can control what happens with your
money the best way to do that is with
every dollar the every dollar mobile app
lets you check your budget from anywhere
and you can always make the right money
decisions and if you're in this with a
spouse the both of you can be watching
the thing together it's pretty amazing
when you get on a budget you'll be in
control of your money start budgeting
for free go to ramseysolutions.com
every dollar claudia is in orlando hi
claudia welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you so much for having me sure
what's up
um all right so my husband and i are on
baby step number two and we're planning
on relocating within the next year we're
debating if we should sell our house now
while the market is high and rent until
we decide where we're moving to
or wait until we're ready to move but
risk the price of the house dipping
if we sell now we could make enough
profit to pay off our debts build an
emergency fund and have the 20 down
payment for our next home um but rents
are around 500. you think you're going
to move in the next 12 months
i yes we will
okay no you don't need to worry about
the price of the house dipping it's not
going to dip in 12 months
okay so you think that we should stay in
the house and then just wait until we're
ready to now yeah it might slow down and
be a little bit more difficult to sell
but the price the value will not go down
all right so no i wouldn't i that's my
prediction now that's worth every dollar
you paid for it right
you know economists and weather
forecasters are the only ones that can
be wrong most of the time and keep their
job right
so i'm not either one i'm not either one
but i did look at the weather app
earlier and um
so no i i honestly i mean i've been
doing real estate for 40 years
and i i've watched it a lot the number
of times that real estate prices went
down
in my lifetime is once
that was 2008
they've not gone down
okay now in certain neighborhoods they
might go down but that's a neighborhood
problem it's not an economy problem
okay now what is going what is going to
happen is interest rates continue to go
up and as some of these uh supply chain
and inflationary things smooth out
probably the price the rate of price
increase on houses is going to slow so
like last year in 2020 uh or 2021 we saw
a 32 percent increase
in 22 we're projecting a seven percent
increase
in house prices so the the increase is
going to slow down but that's different
than it going down in value we do not we
don't have any indication the data we're
seeing at ramsey that's going to go down
in value so i would not go to the
trouble to sell it early get yourself go
through all this crap have to move oh
god and go rent for a year now all just
because you're afraid it's going to go
down no you can hear everyone who's
shopping for houses right now
collectively grown
it's like oh man but
they're not going down yeah they're not
going down they're just not there's too
much of a shortage
there's i mean we still have way too
many buyers chasing too few sellers
right now it's still still that and
that's that's not going to subside
completely in one year and go the other
direction
i mean how it would have to happen for
house prices to go down you have to have
a complete inverse of where you are
right now had to be 10 houses for sale
for every buyer
instead of 10 buyers for every seller
and that's not going to flip that
dramatically in one year it's just not
going to do it well for all the people
who just groaned i'm in i'm in there
with you we're currently in the market
for a house and can feel your pain but
i guess that's the yeah it's just it's
going to go up it's going to go up it's
just a matter of how much
and
hopefully it will calm down
because this white hot
is not good for anybody no it's it makes
the sellers crazy it makes the buyers
crazy makes the real estate agents crazy
they were already crazy i mean it's just
it's crazy everywhere it's just it's no
fun
coleman is in uh billings montana hi
coleman welcome to the ramsay show
hey how's it going better than i deserve
what's up
so i have two statements and one
question so first off
me and my wife just got married two days
ago
congratulations statement
thank you the second statement is that
we are both doctors and we
came together with 430 000 in student
debt so my question is
i know you guys state that we have that
it takes about 18 to 24 months to get
out of debt
for us it's projected to be about six
years
we were just curious on some ideas on
how to say gazelle intense but as well
we'd like to enjoy life our pre-marriage
counselors
work with uh doctors and they really
noted that there needs to be times of
enjoyment and we just we're curious on
how we may do that
okay
well i i always use big numbers
in my math
and so
um
what is your income going to be
two dollars for the next
yeah for the next so she will be in
residency for three years oh so we will
have roughly 128 000 a year and then
after those three years it should jump
up to 2
30 250.
and sh and you i thought you said you
were a doctor
yeah i'm a doctor of physical therapy so
oh pt okay
yeah yeah so what are you making 80
i will be making about 70. yeah okay
starting out okay so you got 200 000
income for three years
uh 128 for three years
oh she's only going to be she's going to
be making 61 i'll be making oh i
misunderstood that that was your
household in that site yeah okay correct
yep sorry
when you say enjoying life what does
that look like to y'all
so
me and my spouse's passion is traveling
hiking in the mountains and a lot of
family time and with her getting
accepted to a residency program a few
hours away from home
to see family it would cost
i mean a good chunk of change each time
why you get in the car and you drive
over there
i it's a like a five hour drive and then
hotels to stay in
well my thought is okay here's the thing
um
earl nightingale used to say
that the problem with achieving a goal
is not that what we have to do to get to
the goal it's what we have to give up to
get to the goal
so you you your your counselor
um
is an idiot
your pre-marriage counselor
um because here's the thing
you know you want to define enjoyment of
life as having 430 000 crushing you from
the top down
while you go running around acting like
you don't have debt and call that
enjoying life
um i don't i don't agree
i think that's really bad advice
and so i think there's a lot of things
you can do to enjoy life a lot of broke
people have really a lot of enjoyment in
their life
and dude you are seriously broke
i mean seriously bro
430
thousand dollars worth of screwed
you are so broke it's unbelievable how
broke you are and the sooner you guys
just own that
the better off you're gonna be and quit
walking around acting like it's all okay
it's not okay now are you gonna clean
that up in three years no you're not
gonna clean that up in three years
making 110
you're not gonna do that but y'all have
made a serious dad gum mess and we want
to travel
sorry
when you signed up for this doc thing
you you kind of cashed in the travel
card for a while
i mean you may get to travel some and
drive over and see mama some mama may
come over to your place and see you some
but
i mean dude y'all have a mess
and
yeah
and i think you can redefine your
definition of enjoying life like
mountains hiking that's all free stuff
you can still do that while paying off
this debt my husband and i used to do
trip tuesdays where we went on trips to
little national parks and you know we
were college age i was college age broke
and you know that cost what 20 30 bucks
in gas just to get there and hide and do
something else that and you know if we
want to call that enjoying life have at
it that's fine you want to call dropping
20 grand on travel annually
because that's called enjoying life
because my counselor said to then your
counselor is an idiot
that's you know i'm just not gonna i
want you to understand what you're
dealing with you have a mess and you
have to pay a price to clean this mess
up that puts this hour of the ramsey
show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace
ramsaysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
you